the obamas officially said goodbye to  the White House on Friday as Donald  Trump became the 45th President of the  United States hi donald john Trump do  solemnly swear that I will faithfully  execute that I will faithfully execute  the office of President of the United  States the office of President of the  United States Obama sent a message via  Twitter just before the inauguration  ceremony promising to stay with the  American people and continue his work he  added quote it's been the honor of my  life to serve you you made me a better  leader and a better man Barack and  Michelle breeded Trump and his wife  Melania at the White House before they  headed to the Capitol the Obamas oldest  daughter Malia is also set for a new  role the 18 year old has accepted an  internship with Hollywood heavyweights  Harvey Weinstein Malia is also set to  attend Harvard University this fall  you